hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my four meters yinka who
asked what makes your business unique so
I think in my case I really focus in on
expertise so when I'm talking to
entrepreneurs a lot of the questions
that they're asking I've been through
before and so I just tap into my
expertise to be able to help them out so
I've started a company built it sold it
worked at a venture capital company
raising expansion money for companies
have done a lot of media have done a lot
of online marketing and so I just try to
tap into the things that I've already
done to be able to help entrepreneurs
out I don't try to talk about things
that have no idea about you lead people
down the wrong path but the expertise
that i have i think really helps make my
business unique and when I'm talking to
corporations they're interested in my
expertise in kind of understanding the
entrepreneur community and how to market
to entrepreneurs and what entrepreneurs
are kind of going through so i think the
expertise really what makes my business
unique i'd love to hear what you guys
have to say what makes your business
unique if you want to leave a comment
underneath or if you want to leave a
nice thumbs up for this video those are
always appreciated so I love to hear
from you and stay tuned for the next
episode
you